we are a rumor recognizable only as deja
vu and dismissed
this is quickly we are the best kept
secret in the universe I know I want in
you erase my parents memories that you
didn't get mine took me 20 years to find
you everybody loves to see you two
together it took pun it suits you
and I know that people have sort of
asked about what franchise you might do
next together there's been a bodyguard
thing between the two of you is that a
joke that it was my fault I think it is
a joke but the reverse right drama drama
yeah I I came in one day after the
weekend or whatever and I was like yeah
you came in on a Monday the bodyguard
last night I was like what and then I
say yeah I can do that and you could
want the role yeah we're gonna swap it
can you sing I will always love you
yeah the damsel in distress it would you
have to take the bullet for me like I
would take a bullet for you but you'd
like to try a few other 90s ideas Dirty
Dancing I think could be great in the
rumors reversing they're all really old
movies I got we actually talked about
yeah that'd be cool be amazing while we
were making this film like the sort of
cat you know Hepburn Tracy I really my
girl Friday that that sort of yeah feel
like that would be good together some of
the it hasn't been reading much very
much actually that would be fantastic
see I was
really recently so your goat means
mm-hmm have become stuff of legends I'm
sure you're aware of goats
I love goats and I there's a visit
Twitter handle the post a photograph of
me every day with a corresponding coat
that looks like me and it's amazing it's
an actual does not like like an actual
pencil but I was wondering if you were
going to give Chris and go animal if
you're gonna sign him an animal which is
which animal or would you would just
sign yourself like pneumonia we got a
lot of animals in the house they got
donkeys you do yeah with three donkeys
three horses to Rob before rabbits human
to guinea pigs to chickens
dog and a bearded dragon and I don't
even know this at him come ah Wow well
so would you choose one of those what
would you choose for Chris from what we
don't choose I saw the fish face thing
you did that very well um a unicode do
you have like a spirit do you have an
animal that you connect to spiritually
what do you want you would look at
dolphin oh yeah you really should do a
fish because you're a surfer and the
whole thing did you talk to will and
Tommy at all and if not was there one
element from the original that you said
I really want to bring that into this
film that was important to you or
something that was really important to
you just bring fresh I didn't know we
didn't fake them I mean the script
they'd formed their sort of freshness I
think what was appealing international
sort of aesthetic look to it you know
all the different locations we've shot
on and you know this father is like a
location informs a different tone of
your character anyway so that kept
shifting throughout the film which was
great there's a sequence in it that I
actually pitched to Walter and Laurie
our producers that sort of hearkened
back to something that happens in the
original film when will is first in the
office and he sort of has a mishap and
it sets things
awry just this idea of like a rookie
someone that is confident and knows
themselves but they're in a new space
and I thought that we could use some
more of that and also just for me I was
really excited to do something that felt
physical I've never done real physical
comedy in that way so there's a little a
little like shout out to will in the
original film for the next movie for the
next men in black and I thought you
could each pick one for the other to try
it oh oh you're gonna try you're gonna
pick those for yourself how I love that
[Laughter]
oh my gosh actually those really goes
well with your suit yeah you like him
these are freaking me out
Joey I thought that we were here we are
you go to edge weight are you a queen
I pledge loyalty a turtle to you know
I'm not interested too late I already
pledged the loyalty I wish you'd said no
no no before I like the facial hair oh
thank you I cut it too short by mistake
it was longer it'll get growing a full
beard no it was just a little bit fuller
than this and then my wife was using the
trimmer her heads shaved on the side and
then it was she changed the setting this
is not an interesting story here's the
rest of it I just did it a little bit
and I was like oh no I messed up and
[Laughter]
find a way to segue but I don't think
it's possible but I do have I know
you're an x-file er you're a believer
you've tweeted about you know alien
existence so is men in black
international a documentary what it
makes me sound like a crackpot I don't
believe her - I lied all this I don't
believe in Bigfoot Loch Ness monster
chupacabra vampires okay werewolves but
aliens I think it's possible I don't I
men in black is not a documentary
because I don't think they're like
living with us and hanging out don't but
I think they're showing up and you know
they're like doing little tours maybe do
you have any sin firm ation that would
be like
fun little tidbit of stuff that you know
because you do know about this stuff no
I wish I had seen an alien I wish I'd
seen the UFO I would love to see what
I'm being a great guy to see what why
because I'm like pretty reasonable and
if I was like guys I saw UFO people
would be like oh okay baby that's real I
do know people who've seen him didn't
you believe them
I do but they're sort of unreasonable
with the beard you seem very sensible
yes you know totally yeah it's a UFO
tonight it's gonna happen for you it's
gonna happen I'm neuralyzer if you could
have a neuralyzer and use it on anything
you've done in the past career-wise
we'll stick it to the career is there
anything listen get you to race go on my
IMDB okay you'll be able to guess which
ones I want to do realize okay I got
some I got some dogs in there just go on
rotten tomatoes rank my movies by rating
towards the bottom let's look at is
there any hot love for in there that you
were like you know what I really love
that so what should people go to IMDB
and re-watch oh we watch the big sick is
there a person because there's always
there's a nod to the originals in this
movie about certain celebrities yes that
are aliens I won't say who it was
in this film I don't want to spoil it
but who either that you've worked with
or in Hollywood do you say to yourself
they must be an alien oh I didn't mean
in a complementary way because they're
so bleep and talented yeah yeah you can
say yourself I just got to meet Oprah I
wouldn't be surprised if she was an
alien just because she she's so wise and
so kind and so wonderful and I've never
met a human being that has all of that
so yeah I wouldn't be surprised if she's
like a benevolent alien who's here to
usher us to the next stage of evolution
and even if she is a human she is alien
like she's just wonderful um so I
already gave away two pairs of glasses
to Chris and Tessa so I had a choice of
four but because your character
not get sunglasses in this film I didn't
want you to feel left out so I wanted to
know if you wanted to have a Tryon
session with me we're in London just so
people know sure you want it you don't
want it you don't want these those are
actually very reasonable what other way
these are reasonable those are very
reasonable perfect you look great
well they kind of go with my outfit yeah
they're kind of work that's actually
really working with your Hawaiian rest
of my team now if you said that you
spotted an alien in those glasses I
don't know if anybody wouldn't
necessarily that's right that I want to
be a credible with this choice just it
kind of destroys your hypothesis
you